il
très attachante c'est à dire qu'elle va
toujours essayer de faire plaisir
perfectionniste
travailleuse et consciencieuse voilà
c'est bien travaillé je n'ai pas lâché
pas de moi
jean paul loret nice et
je fais la gymnastique c'est ma passion
bonjour de ma maison
enfin côté savent à quel bouger tout le
temps très dynamique quand elle était
petite elle bougeait partout elle doit
qu'il y avait un mur il fallait qu'elle
le monte dessus des caves et une
araignée dans les parcs de jeux
parce qu'en passait notre temps dont les
parcs de jeux vu qu'on habitait en
immeuble cette façon là elle est venue
grâce à mon frère parce que c'est lui
qui m'a entraîné là dedans est tout le
temps et gymnase loup à nantes
et après quand je suis arrivée là j'ai
vraiment commencé à faire des horaires
aménagés et et à vraiment aimer ce sport
vraiment c'est vrai ça a commencé là
vraiment être une passion
et
elle est arrivée dans cette salle elle
avait 6 ans elle a commencé le
dispositif qui existe encore les
horaires aménagés dont elle a fait ses
quatre années de primaire cp ce1 cm1 cm2
ou à l'issue de la classe de cm2 l'aï
senti des champions de france où là elle
essaie d'y aller là j'ai maintenant un
rêve mon rêve c'est de la rio et je me
donne les moyens je quitte ma famille je
quitte mon île et je rentre que deux
fois mais je me donne à fond pour mon
sport et pour atteindre mon rêve mais
c'est lui qui m'a qui m'a vraiment
entraînée dans mes débuts qui m'a fait
progresser vraiment sur lui niveau
basique de la gym et et c'est grâce à
lui que maintenant j'ai ce niveau là
3° on n'a pas trop de choses à commencer
à tout va bien à part ça tout va bien
je crée très chargé qui commence à 7h et
et qui finissent à à 19h30 le soir donc
et à de l'école et de la gym en même
temps jeune fille qui viennent de l'île
de la réunion elles savent pourquoi ils
sont là et c'est la différence entre les
insulaires et les métropoles les métros
elles viennent parce que le système de
détection a fait en sorte qu on les
détecte et qu'on les incorpore dans une
structure d'entraînement
les réunionnaises elles sont là parce
qu'elles ont vraiment envie de faire de
la gymnastique de haut niveau belle le
vie bien parce que premièrement elle a
des résultats
donc ça nous permet de continuer sur
salsa logique de succès de réussite
et puis elle le vit bien aussi parce
qu'elle est avec d'autres réunionnaise
en famille d'accueil
et c'est un petit peu un petit clan j'ai
le temps exact pour pouvoir manger elle
à la gym à l'école ça lui va bien et qui
sont très mignonne au début tu étais là
est bon et m'ont demandé de l'appeler
mamie donc pour elle elle m'appelle
mamie ses ailes sont elles fait adorable
avec moi le ton et aura bon jpack i a
pas des fois au japon d'un pub assez
lâchant mondor tout violet pigment jaune
ouais parce que c'est notre espace où on
dort après ya un espace où l'espace on
se détend avec lattes et nos corps
si ça me permet d'avoir chaque jour leur
état de coups quotidiens de ce qu'ils
ressentent le matin doivent donner
l'éducation sursaut mais si elles vont
bien dormir
c'est ce que j'aime faire gêné et j'ai
commencé à temps que je finisse parce
que ça me plaît et puis et puis que je
suis arrivé vraiment haut niveau donc
c'est pas un moment de machines lohan
étant un standard européen à l'heure
actuelle les jeunes filles on banalise
le fait que ce sont des gymnastes qui
sont sûres sur le la préparation des
championnats du monde de championnat
d'europe c'est notre quotidien
mais c'est grâce à l'om ça parce
qu'elles vivent une expérience de leur
vie un peu extraordinaire parce que
partir de l'île déjà depuis 4 ans et
ce sont des concessions pas ça si la
terre est là elle se retrouve en fait en
groupe
donc 5 maintenance du même club en plus
elles sont hébergées dans la même
famille d'accueil au delà de
du pari de la gymnastique elles vivent
aussi à l'extérieur une expérience
humaine fantastique
on dirait que c'est la première fois
qu'elle fait un double arrière carpé de
sa vie celle là
voilà la batterie tu vas voir un moule à
mike hulme et réalisons et dansante du
vent ok c'est bien c'est une grande
partie aussi de difficultés c'est ça
c'est pour ça que il n'y a pas beaucoup
de gens qui nous font et que c'est
unique
ça peut paraître beaucoup pour des gens
qui sont extérieurs nous qui sommes dans
la profession depuis très longtemps
c'est un sport qui est très rigoureux et
qu'il n'autorise pas le petit faux pas
c'est déjà demain
leur quotidien et moi je vis pendant
deux semaines c'est en france et touche
robin le sont fiables je veux un truc
tous des monstres de l'essence et du
benzène saisons de 100 épisodes
oh
pour
le
on est à montpellier sur un championnat
d'europe individuel
je pense que ça va être un gros
championnat parce qu'effectivement il
est sur la route olympique
il y a beaucoup de médias il ya beaucoup
de concurrence internationale
toutes les nations sont comme nous dans
cette préparation olympique et viennent
aussi expérimenté ou tester leurs
sportifs feront nous avons des objectifs
de médailles pour la délégation france 3
médailles en tout tous les garçons d'un
potentiel de médaille chez les filles
c'est peut-être un peu plus difficile
parce qu'elles sont beaucoup plus jeunes
voilà notamment l'eau à nice de l'île de
la réunion qui fait son premier
championnat d'europe seniors
la gym on dit souvent que ou même le
sport de haut niveau on dit souvent que
c'est une école de la vie et c'est vrai
parce que on apprend à découvrir
vraiment notre corps dans tous les
recoins
et louise a les deux
ouais c'est incroyable moi qui voulait
lui faire un petit bisou sert à terre
pierre
elle a encore beaucoup de choses à
prouver mais bon
c'est déjà bien
j'aime bien
probable
bonjour
vous devez juste réparé une petite
un petit quart d'heure hier
non mais si tu me dis non je vais
marcher sur tout
saoul après jour
ici
ça va
à jaser
un peu trop de pression
nous on va souvent aux france
c'est passé pour que
c'est quelque chose que tu sais faire
qu'est-ce que qu'est ce qui s'est passé
qu'est-ce qu'on c'était quoi les
consignes tout simplement
au top exactement ce que je sais faire
complètement déçus parce qu'on sait bien
que sfr donc maintenant voilà donc oui
déçu pour elle parce que elle se doit
une joie de faire plaisir de se faire
plaisir
voilà peu mais ceci dit c'est avant tout
c'était l'expérience qu'il fallait
engranger
je pense qu'elle a une bonne dose
d'expérience même si au final c'est les
larmes
cette affaire ne passera les larmes de
joie c'est pas la fin du monde on est
s'est pas notre vie qui est en jeu donc
faut pour relativiser et passer passer à
autre chose comprendre pourquoi ça n'a
pas été ce moment-là et et savoir
modifier ça pour les prochaines étapes
faux
le
aux assauts l'âge de revenir ici parce
que parce que c'est là je sais que quand
je rentre c'est pour des vacances donc
facebook ainsi et puis et puis c'est
passé pas les mêmes les mêmes paysages
ni la même chaleur bas la suite et je
m'en vais à rio pour les jo en 2016 avec
la qualification monde
sont talentueuses très peu ne vont pas
avoir le même parcours qu'elle parce que
il va manquer quelque chose il va
manquer la cellule familiale il va
manquer le sérieux de deux filles
quand je dis perfectionniste et on
n'arrive pas ce qu'il veut sans cette
perfectionniste c'est pas possible
qu'elle soit équilibré qu'elle soit
heureuse mais qui surtout qu'elle
réalise son rêve qu'elle a depuis l'âge
de 12 ans
madame beauchamp
super fier
et la cites la réunion vise à riom
vt